le
premier pour son premier déplacement en
tant que candidat emmanuel macron a
choisi de se rendre à poissy ce lundi 7
mars pour une réunion publique le fief
de son ami et maire divers-droite karl
olive à l'appel du président samedi soir
aux alentours de minuit et une heure du
matin pour mieux je commencerai bien ma
campagne de terrain chez toi et puis il
ne voulait absolument pas un meeting
politique en tant que tel c'est à dire
avoir que des militants autour de lui
c'est pas ça qui souhaitait le président
il souhaitait avoir des gens qui
n'avaient pas forcément voté pour lui en
2007 c'était le cas je travaille pas de
secrets en tant que la moitié de la
salle n'a pas forcément voté pour lui en
2017 avait besoin d'éléments pour
récolter ces éléments les 250 personnes
invitées au centre de diffusion
artistique ont pu poser leurs questions
au président candidat au programme des
thématiques sur la guerre en ukraine
l'immigration encore le pouvoir d'achat
tout à l'heure je suis parti prendre
donc mettre de l'essence dans mon
véhicule et j'ai vu plus de 2 euros
monsieur le président est ce que vous
vous rendez compte que plus de deux
euros c'est juste énorme pour un
français moyen
et j'ai en plus trois enfants à court
terme les prix le pouvoir d'achat ce que
vous avez dit est parfaitement vrai vous
avez été la porte parole mon avis de
dizaines de millions de françaises et de
français
sur les prix de l'énergie
si je puis dire le président n'a pas
attendu le candidat du gouvernement a
pris déjà beaucoup de mesure et on doit
aller pour suivre la situation dans
lequel dans laquelle je me trouve c'est
la situation dans lesquelles se trouvent
tout le monde et tout le monde est
impactée quelles que soient leurs
revenus
des familles un échange direct qui s'est
parfois déroulées dans une ambiance
détendue merci monsieur président
d'ailleurs mes collègues me regardent et
attendent la réponse est ce que je peux
venir à côté de vous pour prendre une
photo s'il vous plaît
ce premier rendez vous en tant que
candidat était aussi l'occasion pour
emmanuel macron de mobiliser ses équipes
sur le terrain mais maintenant c'est
notre rôle à chacune et chacun des
militants des élus des responsables
associatifs des citoyens qui se retrouve
dans le discours du président est bien
de convaincre sur le terrain et on a 35
jours pour le faire emmanuel macron
reviendra dans les yvelines ce jeudi 10
mars avec une autre casquette celle du
président du sommet européen organisé à
versailles avec les 27 chefs d'état des
pays de l'union européenne